indeed a good start for the star
frenchman uh
cognac is actually a city in france i
got a chance to visit
that city slash town if you will
this home of hennessey the hennessey
brand which i have represented maxim the
word cognac brings any pleasant memories
to your mind
i've never been to cognac actually
so i don't have any story time like
yasser does
um and i might have drank cognac once in
my life but uh it's too strong for my
poor taste
okay well
let before we get to your game bot
vinnick any about winning stories for
you any influence that he's had in your
chess career
uh well of course i
never could meet him because
well
he passed away before i even started to
play chess but
he was
one of the great he serialized
a lot of things a lot
like more than opening preparations a
way to prepare the way to
get fit for your games and so on and
of course it is
the first one or most i would say is
that kind of theorized soviet school of
chess
definitely a huge contribution to the
world of chess
now you have been sitting on the side
watching these guys punish each other in
the saint louis wrapping in blitz how
eager were you to jump in or did you
want them to keep playing get tired get
tired get tired so i could come in fresh
no at some point i wanted to
to play because you know there's only so
much you can do uh while waiting and
it gets
you know
difficult and
well what i'm used to as a chess player
is to play chess to prepare for the
games and you know to to get busy so
so i was
really looking forward to play today all
right so you came out the gate and you
decided i'm gonna go back
to play h4 on move three you're normally
an e4 player that we know and you said
peter plays the grunfeld i play to grind
phil what is he going to do about my h4
move
why this specific move today
well it just became
the main line against the grandfather
unexpectedly and
there's uh
a lot of things that can get tricky for
for black i thought peter reacted well
played
a very sensible line uh
but in the end i
still keep that a small amount of
pressure did you feel that you had an
advantage somewhere down
let's say here
maybe even a little bit further down in
the game more like
where i'm going to go further when your
queen is actually
well here no no here you're winning i'm
going back too far i'm going down too
far let's go
here for example he could take on b5 did
you feel you would maintain an advantage
in this position
well after knight b5 are playing h6 and
it's uh quite unclear bishop f6 knight
b5 you play a6 yeah h6 here bishop f6
and i thought
it's probably wonderful uh i wasn't sure
maybe uh i wanted some e5 even though i
was not sure this uh e5 in this given
position yeah i'm not sure it works but
uh you know i might have
tried it but definitely i was not
expecting okay eight which is also very
sensible move
um
but from there on everything gets really
kind of forced and you have to see king
e8 which you should
uh i mean all the way here yeah
ea
yeah
i mean i thought k8 i would retain some
pressure i also thought about c4 the one
thing i liked about my position is uh
well i mean
peter blender that after a bit xc5 he
couldn't take with the queen after 98.
but from afar
uh
no
bishop uh
c5
oh yeah threatening queen h8 yeah
but after before i thought that first
his idea would have been queen a6
but what's nice is that it just loses
because i take i play b5
then i bring my point to b7 and my
bishop to a5 knight b8 saying b6 k8
b7 king d7 bishop a5
my king is
close enough from the c5 pawn and
there's nothing you can do really in
this position
um so
but yeah 98
was a presence so i thought after before
he should go either k8 i was hoping to
have some trick
probably i don't
um
because i can get this h7 pawn but at
the same time
i guess my bishop probably gets a
perpetual so
and c4 felt kind of critical but after
c4 i'm assuming i retain nice age yeah
with queen a7 yeah actually i do this
would be quite strong 98 i assume this
would be much better for me but
the same time i didn't see a clear win
but of course
of course king eight was uh
when you won this tournament
a few years ago four years four years
now wow time flies exactly
you also won round one you won your
first game
bodes well for the rest of the
tournament or just a game
um well it's a game it was a tough game
i'm very happy with the results i'm not
going to make any prediction about my
final results but
my team will
try to
to be prepared for somebody somebody
predicted you to win this whole
tournament was it
it was alejandro wow and what happened
the last time i picked him to win the
sing field cup going against your man
fabi
well i stole fabi he stole five stars
yeah you start fabbing yeah so you have
to go with somebody else but he picked
you right away nice
i'll try to honor his uh
great wisdom
of course
thanks very much for joining us good
luck in the rest of your games thank you
maui thank you and yeah as just looking
at the game